le 31 décembre 2019 une compagnie
canadienne blue dot de toronto repères
27 premiers cas de pneumonie suspectes
autour d'un marché d'animaux à wuhan en
chine et elle alerte les autorités
celles aiguille dans la botte de foin
les algorithmes de blue dot analyse des
millions de sources d'information et ses
experts découvrent ce qui deviendra la
grande pandémie ou neuf jours avant l'
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
les pêcheurs ont démarré tôt le docteur
kamran khan avait reconnu il y a trois
mois quelque chose de similaire à
l'épidémie de sras ce qu'ils avaient
fait des ravages dans sa ville de
toronto en 2003 cette épidémie a été
l'inspiration de la création de blue dot
nous voulons repousser les frontières de
l'utilisation des données de l'analyse
et de la technologie pour aller toujours
plus vite
si nous pouvons devancé ces maladies
infectieuses nous devons aller plus vite
qu'elle elles vont très très vite
pourquoi la chine le reste du monde et
les clients et partenaires de blue dot
n'ont pas réagi à cette alarme de fin
décembre
mystère d'autres entreprises en
intelligence artificielle sont entrés
dans la course contre la copie de 19 une
firme de san francisco keynes à vent des
thermomètres intelligent relevé un
réseau ce qui permet de détecter à
l'avancé les zones de maladies atypique
en fonction des relevés de fièvre sa
carte permet de dégager la tendance de
la propagation généralement de la grippe
mais depuis le 1er mars dernier de
lakovic 19
les données recueillies dans les
infirmeries des écoles sont
particulièrement instructive
une autre firme de toronto à but non
lucratif la tonne point ca a mis au
point un site web
celui ci recueille des données à travers
tout le canada pour tracer une carte qui
montre en temps réel l'évolution de la
propagation du virus et lorsqu'on aura
plati la cour comme on semble l'avoir
fait en asie et pour empêcher qu'elles
remontent que fait-on les chinois ont
dans leur téléphone portable
une application qui atteste de leur
santé et de leur niveau de risque auprès
des autorités en code vert
tout est bon on peut utiliser les
transports publics hong kong impose des
bracelets à tous ceux qui arrivent de
l'étranger ce qui permet de les suivre
dans tous leurs déplacements
l'état vous surveille au canada un
groupe de chercheurs privilégie un autre
modèle
il va falloir que les gens installent
sur leur téléphone une application qu'on
est en train de développer on n'est pas
les seuls enfin ça se passe partout dans
le monde et à ce moment là quand les
gens qui ont leur téléphone en poche se
promène sa va enregistrer les les le
fait que vous étiez à peu près au même
endroit à peu près bon moment avec tel
autre personne mais de manière anonyme
singapour offre l'application source
libre à voici comment tristes ou gais de
singapour fonctionne pas de
géolocalisation c'est la fonction
bluetooth qui rentrent en contact avec
les téléphones voisins dans un rayon de
10 mètres
le programme volontaire informe les
usagers de l'état de santé de ceux qu'il
rencontre et les alertes en cas
d'infection les cas sont détectés
soigner et les personnes côtoyées sont
identifiés et informe les données sont
en crypté anonyme et demeure dans les
téléphones qui ne sont connectés à aucun
réseau on travaille très fort pour
essayer de déployer ça le plus vite
possible
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
vient aussi de lancer une application en
source libre pour partager ces données
par géolocalisation avec les
utilisateurs et les responsables de la
santé publique
jean michel leprince sera du canada